i have a very clear memory of playing
time splitters future perfect for hours
and hours over one rainy easter weekend
back in 2005. i was 13 i had a generous
supply of chocolate eggs a tiny crt tv
and most importantly no responsibilities
whatsoever it's one of those blissful
memories that if you grew up playing
games will be permanently etched in your
mind
life was good
[Music]
now look at me
when i was growing up i played time
splits 2 and future perfect on an almost
constant basis with my mates enjoying
its mad split screen multiplayer and
trying to get every challenge mode medal
but it's been 16
long years since the last time splitters
game and shooting games in particular
have changed pretty dramatically since
then so how well does time splitters
hold up in 2021
nowadays it's surprisingly difficult to
actually find a way to play them if you
don't have access to the original
consoles the only time splitters game to
get any kind of a modern remaster is
time splitters 2 whose story mode can be
found hidden away on an arcade cabinet
in home front the revolution they don't
even appear on xbox's list of backwards
compatible games there's also the fan
produced time splitters rewind project
but that is still some way off from
completion back in may deep silver
announced the reformation of free
radical design creators of the original
time splitters trilogy to be led by
original co-founders steve ellis and
david doke who have just a little bit of
experience creating great shooter games
and haze not only that but free radicals
first task is a new entry to the beloved
time splitters franchise brilliant i
thought with e3 around the corner surely
a remastered trilogy is on the cards but
sadly e3 came and went with neria monkey
in sight so
i just got to sit here twiddling my
thumbs right i mean what am i gonna do
borrow my partner's dad's old ps2 which
only has one half working third party
controller buy an hdmi adapter so it
works with the only tvs that i've got
and try and scrounge up copies of the
games from whatever secondhand shops
have them locally
yeah
before i relive my childhood here's a
little history lesson to get everyone up
to speed time splitters was released
exclusively for playstation 2 way back
in the year 2000 and if that makes you
feel odd don't worry because the game
feels even older unlike later entries
time splitter's story mode is a bare
bones trudge through boilerplate levels
to retrieve a key followed by a mad dash
back the way you came as for multiplayer
it's the usual selection of modes and
maps and shares the single player's
chaotic n64 shooter feel and rounding
out the feature set is a map maker and a
challenge mode that only unlocks upon
completing the story mode i never had a
ps2 growing up and the world isn't
exactly conducive to split screen gaming
right now so it's hard to really get a
sense for how it would have been at
launch according to the box revered
gaming magazine edge claimed it was the
game worth buying a playstation 2 for so
it must have been pretty good but having
grown up playing the sequels to me it
all feels a little bit first draft it
does at least set the tone for the
series i mean where else can you shoot
gingerbread men ducks and elvis
impersonators in the same game
but even if you loved the first game i
think it's fair to say that time splits
2 is where free radical really hit their
stride
time splitters 2 featured a proper story
mode across a variety of sprawling
levels with extra objectives or
complications appearing depending on
difficulty level much like golden eye
and perfect dark the location and time
hopping story took in settings as varied
as notre dame siberia alien planets and
a rainy neo tokyo all the way in the
distant future of uh
2019 along the way you'll face off
against soldiers zombies robots the
titular time splitters themselves and
perhaps most nefarious of all
this spiral staircase that for some
reason gave me such intense motion
sickness that i had to go for a lie down
stairs aside it's astonishing how well
it holds up in 2021 and how much variety
is crammed into every single level the
opening mission alone sees you
infiltrate a compound sneak through the
interior investigate a mysterious
digging site uncover cells full of
zombies and mutants fight your way back
out as special forces arrive and destroy
a helicopter from some kind of bridge i
mean damn it is an absolute treat
featuring the kind of creative
open-ended design that is sorely missing
from so many single-player campaigns in
modern first-person shooters
and then there's the mighty player
oh man the multiplayer
there's two variants of arcade mode with
the arcade league challenging you to
pre-set scenarios each with their own
absurd lawlets as if you need them and
then the endless toy box fun of arcade
custom it is chaotic messy uncomplicated
fun with a wealth of customizable
options characters maps weapons and if
all that isn't enough the map maker
returns to let you create your own
levels once you're bored of the usual
lot it's a feature set that puts modern
games to shame topped off with the
improved challenge mode that sees you
beheading undead smashing windows with
bricks or sneaking past cameras to earn
medals expect this to return with a
vengeance and online leaderboards in any
future time splitters game if you're
anything like me it's no surprise that
time splitters 2 became a staple of your
multiplayer gaming back in the early
noughties
time splitter's future perfect the third
game in the series shifts the balance of
its single-player campaign to lose some
of the sandbox feel in favor of some
halo-esque bombast as well as adding a
more developed but incredibly cheesy
story into the mix it certainly makes
more of its larger-than-life characters
though whether that's a good thing is
debatable some of the character designs
have aged poorly and some are just plain
annoying are you sure bean this whole
area is about to be bombed to kingdom
come i mean what is that accent supposed
to be
with those caveats aside it's still an
enjoyable romp if not quite as free-form
as its predecessor challenge mode
returns complete with remote controlled
cat racing obviously and the multiplayer
offers more characters to choose from a
few bigger maps and expanded map maker
is basically everything you'd expect
from a sequel to time splitters 2. much
the same but much more of it
playing these games again in 2021 it's
interesting to think where a remaster or
a sequel would sit in the pantheon of
modern day first-person shooters i mean
in retrospect i'm kind of glad we
skipped a few generations we probably
missed out on a misjudged grim reboot in
the 360 generation where everything's
gray and brown and we've probably
avoided a shoehorned time splitters
battle royale mode too
[Music]
actually that does sound pretty good
i mean i'd be rubbish at it the trilogy
also feels like a kind of window into a
lost era of gaming there are 150
characters in future perfect multiplayer
if it was released now how many do you
think would be locked behind dlc season
passes or pre-order bonuses there's no
xp grind no time limited events seasonal
tie-ins or pay-to-win weapons excuse the
nostalgia but they're like a peek into
the innocent halcyon days of console
gaming that are probably never coming
back the other side of that coin is that
it come from a kind of bygone era of
console gaming before online multiplayer
really took hold and to me that's kind
of a crucial part of their charm
in my head the time splitters games are
always going to be split screen couch
co-op party games they're games that
deserve to be played with your mates in
easy reach for high fiving
or punching if the new time splitters
game can capture the tone the character
and the chaos of the originals it will
feel like a total outlier in modern
shooters too many games are drab and
serious too many multiplayer games ask
you to dedicate an inordinate amount of
time to them if you want to stay
competitive if a time splitter's sequel
is to stay true to the originals it
needs to carry on in that spirit and
just focus on giving players a good time
not enough games lean into uncomplicated
fun or the chance to be downright silly
not enough games capture that feeling
when you're 13 you've got tons of
chocolate and not a care in the world
i'm sure i'm not the only one looking
forward to the next time splits game so
let me know in the comments down below
what you would like to see in the
meantime if you've enjoyed the video
drop us a like and if you want to see
more content like this hit subscribe
thanks very much for watching i'll see
you next time
[Music]
so
[Music]
you